all right give me another clip is what
Hamas did on October 7th an act of
terrorism I think pierce it is pedling
Asin entities for you to pretend that
enslaving you sound like Jeremy Corbin
no let me answer the question 15 times
he refused to answer the question let me
answer the
questionus you're now about three or
four if you L are they a terror group or
not they're one team's freedom fighter
and they're deemed a terrorist do you
think I think that if you lock people in
an open air prison and steal their land
they're going to retaliate so they're
not a terror group I think they're going
to retaliate they're not a terror group
one team's terrorist is now about eight
are they a terror group and also another
thing I want to make clear to you only
Jeremy Corbin has done this done what
refuse to answer the question I think
that what they are doing is seemly
deemed an act of Terror by the people
that the terror these weasly words
they're not weasly of course the
Israelis think they're a terror group
and of course some of course the
Palestinians think they're Freedom
Fighters it's stupid that you're asking
the question of the Civilized world
thinks they're a terror group Committed
an act of terrorism it's not difficult
what they did was an act of terrorism I
think that Israel continues to to
conduct acts of terrorism on the
Palestinian people they're going to do
nothing but strengthen the reaction
going I'm that's a different
conversation I'm about to have with you
about Israel's response but before I get
there one more time is Hamas a terror
group who committed an act of terrorism
I think that when you lock people in an
open air prison you're going to have to
expect retaliation no because I have to
there's people who are firstly first
thingss I want to say perod you don't
mind me saying I think it's spineless
sure I do that's fine you sound like
Jeremy Corbin well that that is did you
see my interview with him no right 15
times last week I asked him the same
question 15 times he prevaricated and
wouldn't answer eventually when someone
does that enough times you know what
they really think you don't think
they're a terror group let me you don't
think they're a terror group no what I
think is this on certain i' be really
curious what you think an act of Terror
is if it's not massacring 1,500 innocent
people including Holocaust Survivors
kidnapping babies decapitating people
cutting their limbs off in women yeah
talk about missing limbs we're going to
talk about that when we talk about what
done but when we get there it'll be in
the context of you not admitting that
was an act of let me answer the question
for the final time I am a realist and as
a realist sometimes you do not come to
the conclusion of labeling good guys and
bad guys the world is not black and
white bad guys the world is not black
and white the world is actually very
gray anybody who sits and thinks there's
clearly a good guy clear a good guy and
clearly a bad guy does not understand
how the world works and as a realist
what you do is you look at scenarios and
you understand why they happen how
unfortunate they are how unfortunate the
loss of human life is how civilians die
on both sides how Innocents are dying in
a chess game played by the elites on
both sides both sides you have innocent
people who didn't even vote for the
person making the decisions who are
ensuring their death signing their death
warrant it's unfortunate on both sides
but listen sir you would not Advocate
Russia doing any of the things to
Ukraine that Israel is doing to to to to
Palestine you would not sit has been
doing exactly that Russia has not done a
fraction
of Israel has done pal Russia illegally
invaded a sovereign Democratic country
and has committed a barbaric Rampage
trying to seize as much of Ukraine as it
can bombing maternity hospitals killing
innocent women and don't even try and
have some kind of no no this is genation
of this will a Hamas rocket a tiny Hamas
rocket that can make a pothole in the
road and then they get hit back with
cruise missiles pole in the rug and blow
people up what do you mean it's not
there to make attack it did nothing it
damaged some some shingles if if Russia
decided to then respond with a missile
attack on a hospital and annihilate 800
people do you think that would be
allowed exactly what it has been would
you
Advocate have you seen the state in
marle they level to the ground the
ukrainians did level correct no the
Russians did4 the Russian Mar and and my
question to you is would you Advocate
those reactions me ask you another
question this a question let me ask you
a question this is crazy you know it's
funny it's woke Wednesday and he's not
woke he's not not not everything that
agree that that diverges from some
totally present mainstream right-wing or
leftwing Paradigm is necessarily woke
okay uh he's not he's a kind of a
right-winger he's like a Muslim
is uh brute I guess you know he's he's
not he's got aspects of right-winged to
him and then he's got a very modernist
streak to him and an apparently amoral
at best streak he claims to be Muslim
but you know anywh who it's complicated
with him but I wouldn't call him a lefty
or a woke person but he's just he's also
just not right about what terrorism is
right now go to jus.com slns I've got a
Christmas gift idea that is sure to make
you the hero of the Season we all know
that the holidays get a little hectic
the shopping the cooking the
never-ending list of things to do well
fear not because I've discovered a gift
that is not just thoughtful it's
downright transformative that is the
gift of genell skincare from now until
Christmas genell's most popular package
has a special discount just for our
listeners at Jus cell.com SL nolles
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skincare in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles fine
line skin redness and yes even a sagging
jawline will disappear right before you
rise with J cell's most popular
collection Jus cell promises immediate
effects you'll see results in less than
12 hours guaranteed or your money back
Jus cell made Christmas come early this
year they sent down a ton of products
for our office and everyone looks way
hotter now than they did before Simply
the Best out there go check out jenus
cell you deserve to look and feel your
best this season go to jus.com to get
this incredible Christmas discount every
order today is instantly upgraded to
free express shipping jus.com
NCW today Andrew Tate could say he could
say in a totally coherent way he could
say I I disagree with the very existence
of the state of Israel I think the
regime is illegitimate I don't agree
with what you know whatever Zionism I
don't agree with I think that the
Israelis should go back to Europe or
something I don't you could say all of
those things and still admit that the
Hamas terror attack was a terrorist
attch and he could do that
because the definition of terrorism is
not contingent upon whether or not you
like this regime or that regime or this
nation state or these Borders or those
borders terrorism is when you target
civilians to achieve a political end
that is obviously what Hamas did this is
why we have the Geneva Convention
protections which is to afford certain
uh certain luxuries to combatants in
times of War if they follow certain
rules chief of which is don't Target
civilians because when you target
civilians that's an act of terrorism so
they obviously are that that is what
they do and I guess what Andrew Tay
could say is I support that kind of
terrorism but but he doesn't want to say
that because it doesn't sound good if
you say I support terrorism so he's got
to walk around it and he uses this silly
line one man's terrorist is another
man's Freedom Fighter as if to say that
all of these issues are merely
subjective they're just from from one's
own personal perspective but that's not
true we actually have reason and we can
we can reason about these things this is
why there's an entire notion of just War
Theory just War Justice in going to war
and Justice in conducting war and under
no even mildly serious reading of just
War Theory can you defend what Hamas did
keep going let me ask you a question
because I want to understand your point
of VI actually my interview of you yeah
but but you tried to understand mine I
just want to understand your point of
view if if I believed or if Israel
believed that one of the people in your
house was a terrorist and decided to
destroy your entire house and kill your
entire family would you sit and say well
maybe there was a terrorist inside I
accept that or would you be enraged
genuine question I don't think you can
take an individual person's response
well it's a bunch of individual people
in Gaza they're people individuals with
thoughts and dreams and aspirations
which are being annihilated 15-year-old
girls without legs cuz of cruise
missiles are individual people they're
not cattle people right and so with the
people in Israel October the and that's
why so heinous which is my exact point
but not heinous enough to reach your bar
of terrorism about reach bar of
terrorism it's understanding why things
happen by not saying it you've made your
position clear just as Jeremy Corbin did
and to pretend you're any different is
ridiculous yeah Andrew Tate could is
almost making a a point which
is a criticism of the Israeli policies
in Gaza or the fact that Gaza has
effectively been a kind of an open air
prison or the rec nition that it's
basically an impossible
situation I I think one could make a
serious argument for for those things
what you what you can't make an argument
for is that Hamas is not a terrorist
group they do if terrorism if that word
has any meaning at all they are
terrorists and then he falls back on one
of the stupidest platitudes one man's
terrorist is another man's Freedom
Fighter which is to just concede our
entire reason it's to say no we can't
there's no such thing as objective truth
we can't look at this in any way
detached from our own personal uh
passions about a subject but that's not
true you say no this this Army wore
uniforms came from a legitimate
Authority targeted military targets made
sure that their their uh military attack
was proportional meaning not in terms of
the number of casualties but in the war
aims made sure that the good to be
achieved was was uh greater than the
evil that would be done in the
Commission of it made sure that the war
was being uh undertaken from good
motives meant this that and the other
thing checked all of the boxes it's not
like just War theory is some new idea
that just cropped up we've known about
it since Cicero okay it's developed over
a long period of time but he just throws
his hands up in the air that's the most
woke part of what he just said forget
about Israel or Palestine the most woke
part of what he said is this this
subjectivism this relativism to say oh
well what is Terrorism anyway you know
man like when you really think about it
man that was a great clip huh now whoa
whoa whoa hold up you got to ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael nolles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time